A Tale of Two exes Johnny Depp showing
no signs of shying away from the
spotlight but where is Amber Heard
welcome everybody to Entertainment
Tonight nearly a week after Johnny's
defamation Victory we are learning new
details about what went on inside the
courthouse as Depp takes his career
Renaissance to the streets of tick tock
arriving at court working on music and
on stage with guitars Jeff Beck Johnny's
first Tick Tock featured personal behind
the scenes footage and a message to fans
quote we have walked the same road
together we did the right thing together
all because you cared and now we will
all move forward together Johnny's ex
Amber quickly fired back at the
celebratory post claiming the verdict
sends a bad message to victims of
domestic violence writing as Johnny Depp
says he's moving forward women's rights
are moving backward Johnny was spotted
out today in northern England before
hitting the stage on Sunday he posed
with fans and reportedly racked up a
staggering 62 thousand dollar bill at an
Indian restaurant celebrating his trial
Victory there is no question pending and
I would appreciate it if you wouldn't be
making argument to the jury meanwhile
Johnny's courtroom attorney trial
standout Camille Vasquez just got a big
promotion her firm announced today she's
been elevated to partner as for Johnny's
ex this is humiliating
to go through a source Tales ET Amber is
not in a good place quote she feels very
alone and like she lost a lot of friends
she is sad that people she hoped would
support her didn't Amber's plan right
now is to focus on being a mom spend
quality time with her daughter and stay
out of the Limelight is she able to pay
a 10.4 million dollar judgment oh no
absolutely not we're told Amber's going
through a rough Financial time right now
but during the course of the trial she
apparently was living large staying at
this mansion that rented for 22 thousand
dollars a month speaking of pricey real
estate one of the five penthouses Amber
and Johnny lived in during their
15-month marriage is on the market the
historic condo in downtown L.A is listed
at 1.765 million The Loft space is one
thousand seven hundred and eighty square
feet Johnny talked about the condo on
the stand testifying he let Amber's
sister Whitney stay there she uh needed
a place so we gave her penthouse for
to live in and listen to this new trial
bombshell
dozing off Court sonographer Judy
Bellinger seen here with Johnny told law
and crime Network some of the jurors
actually fell asleep we're the jurors
who were dozing off for the in the back
row front row both both
and it was it was tough because there
was a lot of video deposition
and you know they just sit there and all
of a sudden I'd see their head
foreign